all right before we get started you know
this is the part where i think the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community where millions come together
to take that next step in their creative
journey whether you're exploring new
skills or diving deeper into a passion
you already have but you want to know
more knowledge my friends
and wisdom creative endeavors like
illustration graphic design photography
animation creative writing music film
and video and so much more
gonna give some love to their freelance
and entrepreneurship class it's quite a
thing being able to carve your own path
in the world based on your passions not
everyone finds the ability to do that in
life so if skillshare can help you find
that
there you go an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month in the
first 1 000 of my subscribers to click
the link below get a free premium trial
membership so click the link below
whether you're starting your journey
or continuing your journey you do what's
best for you and thank you once again to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now falcon
in the winter soldier the finale this is
a spoiler warning for falcon of the
winter soldier
the finale alright so spoiler warning
done talking about the finale of falcon
in the winter soldier in which season
two has been teased but i guess it
wouldn't be called falcon in the winter
soldier it would be called
captain falcon and the falcon punch i
almost said it with a straight face so
for this finale
pretty much right out the gate very
early on we see
sam in his cap outfit new captain
america already made my captain falcon
joke there's no more for this video
everybody gets one and i was digging it
i've seen that outfit in the comic books
though i haven't read those comic books
but it was very familiar and i love the
fact that he was just rocking duel
attack
power of flight and power of the shield
using both in tandem then i was like oh
at a point he's gonna need that serum
but later on he
says you know when he's making his big
like hey i'm new captain america and
he's like i'm out here i'm trying to
make a difference it's just me
no serum just me and i was like that is
important that he doesn't get the serum
now i actually
really dig the fact that he doesn't
still didn't care about the red hand
organization i just didn't like they're
the organization that
the show really makes you try to care in
a world of perspectives but i just
i saw them as okay you need them in here
to get the show going
i did laugh when carly tells bucky like
i'm fighting for something bigger than
myself have you ever done that
ever i wanted bucky to be like uh no
never
i just nope it's been all about me i was
glad to see
johnny walker kind of it's like his
redemption
to her you know i mean i don't know how
that works there is still footage
of him bludgeoning an unarmed person to
death out there on the internet at first
he shows up at the cap shield and i was
like how does he have the cap shield
but also sam captain america has the cap
shell but then his cap shield was all
bent up and beat the [ __ ] and i was like
okay i guess he hit up comic-con
and jack's the cap shield from a
cosplayer was like got a cap shield now
but nonetheless he's us
agent is he us agent or is it usa gent
us agent the bummer is the wrap-up of
the show like this show
actually had some interesting
conversations
and then other things were just kind of
sped right through when we find out
sharon carter's the power broker
everybody already knew that like i said
one of the other falcons in the winter
soldier videos i made
the internet sniffed that one out that
wasn't even a mystery dude that's like
they went right past mephisto to like
sharon carter
is the power broker and she gets her job
as an agent back and now she's like hey
i'm on the inside let's make some deals
i'm like
so she's just like she's dug into this
lifestyle
and she's like no i'll get my old job
back but it's all to feed this lifestyle
now i kind of like it bucky has the
conversation with the old guy about
hey i killed your son because i'm the
winter soldier but it just breezes right
past it it was a bummer man like there
were tears and you know it was like the
conversation you could tell was very
hard but then it's just over
it was over when it started i thought it
was going to stay on that for a bit
longer so it's kind of bummed that it
just kind of went past it but it still
is a scene that
one was necessary for bucky two it's it
all comes together to show why
sam is captain america and bucky is
bucky you look at bucky the reason i
like bucky is because he has that damage
he's working on his own [ __ ] he's still
plagued with nightmares yeah he crossed
off all the things in his book and he
gave it to his therapist was like thanks
for all the help
though my friend sam gave a much better
speech than you ever did but yeah thank
you but for captain america i think
sam fits that perfectly he's always been
training to be captain america
especially with that speech at the end i
love that speech at the end
though i do wonder where that speech
that
optimism of the speech ends and reality
then begin blonde division and falcon in
the winter soldier they blur the lines
between
villain and sympathetic character and
while it's leading the audience there
it's really compelling when it then
tells you oh by the way you have to view
them like
this and they just push you over the
edge like that's when it kind of loses
me when it hit me it's like oh wanda's
a villain but she's also sympathetic
it's probably because i
know wanda from a few movies all these
years it's interesting and then when it
tells you like no no you have to
sympathize with her it's like then it
kind of loses me a bit same here with
that red hand organization
the thing is i didn't care about that
organization or the leader as much as i
did wanda but it does ask the question
until it tells you like no no you should
totally
don't call her a terrorist and that's
where captain america's speech happens
i like the speech because i love the
thought experiment i love the hypothesis
i love the conversation because it's
true like labels
these quick labels dehumanize people and
they keep
people from having conversations that is
true but at a point where the captain
america optimism
ends and i go ahead and go yeah but
reality
and the pattern and this i do think
though
a lot of people sing that would be like
yeah absolutely and then they'll go
ahead and throw labels at other people
and go
no but it's totally justified like they
are that label in reality it's just
someone who's
on an opposing perspective from them and
it shouldn't be political but it's made
to be political because the
outlets that talk about it make it
political they politicize it and
weaponize it and in a world where these
political lines have been divided
people tend to want people to ask the
questions and have the conversations
as long as it's seen as on their side
but at what point
is their accountability to the point of
like yeah but
they did fulfill the quota for that
label because if we step back and we're
just like no no i mean
instead of saying terrorists let us ask
why
but is there no such thing as terrorism
now because every terrorist in their
mind's eye is fighting for a good cause
so i suppose we have to be able to be
like yeah that's the label but
let's still ask why but it's true as
long as these dehumanizing labels are
thrown out there
people just generally don't tend to ask
why so it's tough
but that's what i like about it i do
like the fact that it is a tough
conversation it's a tough thought
experiment and so it's one worth having
and i think okay first of all this
tangents why i usually stay out of these
conversations just
stick to the entertainment but that
speech was such a big part of this and i
think it was such a tip of the iceberg
that now i kind of
here we are i know i bag on twitter a
lot
but it's only because i hate it but
don't see this as me
talking [ __ ] about twitter i just think
this is a
this is one of those moments where you
know you gotta things
people organizations individuals you
gotta roll with the times this is one of
those moments i think twitter should
roll with the times i mean twitter is an
outlet where you have politicians
announcing policy on this thing but when
you have such a large
outlet with such a vast reach limit your
thoughts to what is it 280 characters
people are then kind of forced to go
okay what's the label there you go
dehumanizing gets my point across and it
doesn't take up a lot of character space
so i think twitter's built around that
label throwing contest but also that's
what
gets circulation on twitter so it's not
going to change so i appreciate the
conversation that's in here i appreciate
the conversation that cap wanted to have
and even that's one part of sam's speech
i thought his whole speech
he raised some very good points but that
labels thing is one part that stood out
to me because i feel like that's
something that has to do with everybody
we all do it we all give it we all
receive it we all think it's different
when it's aimed at us and in the end of
this episode i'm glad isaiah bradley
finally got his recognition and that's
another thing i
liked about falcon and the winter
soldier you know you have isaiah bradley
and this guy's like dude
[ __ ] america [ __ ] it all and if you have
any pride whatsoever you would never be
captain america but the thing i
liked about that interaction and what
this show did was it showed that you
don't have to agree with someone
verbatim word for word
in order to understand where they're
coming from sam's like no i'm doing
something different
i'm not gonna go your way i'm gonna go
mine and in the end isaiah bradley
has his spot in the whole super soldier
history museum so sam shows him hey i
can change things and when i boil that
down i love the fact that it was
an understanding of perspective that's
what conversations are it was good
it was a good human interaction that's a
great human moment so falcon in the
winter soldier it wrapped up and i
thought it
ended on a strong note the organizations
that i can't call him a terrorist
organization now
the villainous organization the
antagonist organization i didn't really
care about them i just saw them as a
means to get the plot going i loved john
walker until he
i felt like he kind of got dropped like
a sack of potatoes like kind of got
shoved into the background this dude was
one of the more compelling and
interesting characters
in the show i love zemo i love sam and
bucky's chemistry together and in the
end i thought the passing of the torch
to sam being captain america i thought
that was really well done
the audition started the moment we met
him and from the get-go
the dude was always great alright so
captain and the winter soldier have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know i know that's not technically
what it's called and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you